is a man who has been fist bumped by guy
fieris is a man who is a die-hard
chicago bulls fan
you know him you love him from the no
dunks podcast he's a writer for the
athletic he's got
a very deep collection of top shots
we'll talk some top shots and nfts as
well but he's a dear friend of mine
because he showed me around the nba
finals and that will
always be important to me that was so
kind of him it's trey kirby joining the
show ayo
great to have you trey hey yo thanks for
having me ben
i remember those finals fondly as
well great times but if you're thinking
i'm an expert on that kind of stuff then
feeling a little sorry for you buddy i
had like maybe three times more
experience so i just knew how to not get
kicked out of places
but seems to be working out all right
well you do have a shared experience
with me in that we are the types of nba
fans who in july and august when our
team signs players
get overtly excited we think we're
winning the nba championship
but this year it might actually come
true for your chicago bulls how you
feeling are you just on one the last 48
hours
i'm even more on one if you're telling
me they actually got a chance at the
championship
i'm excited though if you win day one
and day two
of nba free agency after the past four
seasons with the bulls it kind of feels
like title number seven
uh so i don't know i was just as excited
about what chicago did
at the trade deadline last year that
didn't work out too well i was very
excited about the what the bulls did
before the 1920 season
bringing in thad young and thomas
sadaranski that didn't work out but ben
i'm thinking this time third time is the
charm it's gotta work out this time
right
well i just love that you've got your
buddy skeets from no dunks who is all
things toronto raptors and he's got to
deal with the emotions of kyle lowry
leaving but then
demar derozan arguably the greatest
raptor of all time
now playing for one of his best friends
teams what was the conversations like
with skeets yesterday about derozan
coming to chicago
wow he feel i i feel like he's excited
for me the same way that raptors fans
and blazers fans were both
very um complimentary of each other when
the norman powell and gary trent jr
trade went down you know the raptors
were talking to the
to the blazers fans said treat them well
blazers fans were saying the same
back to the raptors and that's what it
felt like for me and skeets it's like
you're saying
derozan at some point in time is going
to be honored by the raptors he's one of
their franchise icons
so after a few years down in san antonio
you know
you could argue that derozan brought a
title to the raptors with the way the
kawhi leonard trade went down so he left
on good terms he's heading to chicago
on good terms so yeah skeets was telling
me you gotta treat him well he's gonna
show up for you gets better every single
year
20 points per game in eight straight
seasons a career high and assists last
year the guys still getting better
uh so yeah keith was excited and you
know we already know that derozan looks
great in red and black
so that's a perfect fit as far as i'm
concerned trey kirby joins the show he's
part of the no dunks crew their podcast
you can get it of course on the athletic
and
formerly of the starters on nba tv uh i
love your guys's
take on basketball you guys know i was a
fan before i could call you a friend and
what you guys have been able to build
with your brand is just remarkable
you think about all the twists and turns
you guys have taken in your career
but just for those who aren't familiar
how did you and taz
and and lee and skeets all link up in
the first place
and how do you explain the energy around
no dunks
the podcast started back in 2006
it was skeets and tap and our producer
jd they all went to university together
ryerson university
up in toronto and if i'm not mistaken
the podcast started the very day
after kobe bryant went for 81 against
the toronto raptors like all right we
got to get out here and podcast about
this what the podcast no one knows
but eventually people figured out what a
podcast was i joined in with them
uh in the summer of 2010 that was a big
summer in the nba you know i was happy
to consider myself a free agent
in that class as well signed with the
basketball jones eventually we moved up
to toronto my wife and i in 2011 we were
there until 2013
working on the basketball jones podcast
video show a blog
all for the score television network in
canada then
in 2013 we ended up down here in atlanta
working for turner sports nba tv we're
called the starters then
and now we've moved on to the athletic
uh this has been we just finished up
year two
with the athletic and you know so that's
been 15 years for the guys that started
it i'm on my 11th season
you know i can remember back when all
the guys that the lakers
signed were young guys that's how long
we've been podcasting at this point so
yeah you know it's been quite a journey
uh for us
there's five of us now so it's been a
lot of fun and you know we just
like to continue building in the nba it
feels like in the past 15 years has
gotten
bigger and bigger and crazier and
crazier you know we're talking about
free agency in august
now who knows what's gonna happen next
trey kirby joining the show ben line's
in for rich on the rich eisen show
and through your travels covering the
nba you've formed a connection a
friendship or some type of relationship
with guy fury for people who don't know
guy's a real deal basketball fan
where's your respect and admiration for
guy fury come from trey
years and years of watching diners
drive-ins and dives
uh you know from i don't know 11 o'clock
p.m to 3 a.m they'll put on
on food network time and time again i
think it was
the all-star game in new orleans you
know
guy has landed like you're saying he's a
big basketball fan he said he had just
landed there and i
sent a joke tweet out saying you want to
come judge our dunk contest
this is back we're doing the television
show and lee and i
also on the show would go head-to-head
in a dunk contest on an eight-foot rim
shocked me when guy said yeah i'll do it
got in touch with him he actually came
to the show
uh he ended up helping judge the contest
and
since he's a big basketball fan you know
and the warriors he's a warriors fan in
particular they were really good
though guy would be at pretty much every
nba final during the dynasty aerial
warriors and i would try and link up
with them when we could uh
so it was uh pretty special for me to
actually you know
see guy fieri who i've been watching
since i was in college
suddenly he's on the show that we're
working on that's what basketball gets
for you sometimes pretty
pretty fun stuff then trey you're down
in atlanta now
uh and the hawks have had a resurgence i
found out the hard way that trey young
is for real what's the vibe like in the
city i know the city shuts down when the
united play
i know everybody's obviously geeked up
on football down in that part of the
country but as far as the hawks go and
where they sit in the city
what's it been like being in atlanta and
seeing this run they're going on
oh it was incredible uh we were down at
we call it the fortress
state farm arena for normal people down
here and it was sold out for every game
in the playoffs and that's
similar to how it was back in 2015 when
the hawks were a 60 win team but
that had not been the case in the years
in between but
to see them get even into the playoffs
was impressive with the way the season
started they made the coaching change
halfway through and that really
got the team unified and pointing the
right direction then
uh unfortunately for you ben trey young
made even a bigger jump in the playoffs
going into that first game when he
became the nba's most likable
villain you know hitting the floater
shushing the crowd putting his finger
very high up on his nose uh it got
people fired up
i feel like it won fans for the hawks
not just in atlanta which you know was
excited to have a a basketball team
doing well again but also
around the league you know though it's
been a while since the hawks have had
a marketable start even when they were
at their best
joe johnson and al horford and paul
mills that they're all all-star caliber
players but they don't have necessarily
the cultural cache that trey young does
so
with a flashy player and a young player
that it feels like you can actually
build something around it's been really
exciting to have that happening here in
atlanta especially considering
the way they did the off season last
year they signed a whole bunch of
veterans that were saying
okay it feels like they've got a lot of
players here let's see if they
all pan out if they're able to gel
together took a little bit of time
before they actually got on the same
page but once they did
they looked really good and now you
gotta assume that the future is pretty
bright here in
atlanta especially considering once a
guy like deandre hunter comes back we'll
see how cam reddish progresses
but having that superstar and trey young
that's a huge first building block
trey kirby joins the show you know from
the athletic part of the no dunks crew
check out their podcast always one of my
favorite listens especially this time of
year
because there's certain players that
just become part of your guys's lexicon
part of your language and i feel like as
a bulls fan now
with lonzo and caruso these are guys who
could become
part of the no dunks thing what are you
most looking forward to about having
alex caruso in chicago
i'm hoping that he still gets the lakers
bump i'm hoping he still is a super
famous guy
even if he ends up being the sixth man
on the chicago bulls
but honestly for me it's just exciting
for the bulls to be
a team that is talked about as a
basketball team
because for i don't know it must have
been about 2015 till probably
2021 january 2021
if the balls were in the news and we
were talking about them on the show or
the podcast it was probably for
something bad that happened whether that
be
a fight in practice between bobby portis
and nikola mirotic
or their coach putting in a punch clock
to get everybody to work hard the bulls
were a little bit of a laughing stock
which is not what you want from one of
the bigger franchises in the league so
the fact that they have
started acting like a major market and
trying to put some wind on the
scoreboard
it's exciting to me to have the ball be
a relevant team you know
they came down to the final couple of
weeks of the season trying to get into
the play in this year
and to me that felt like going for
championship number seven just the bulls
trying to get the 10th feed to play one
more game
in this play-in tournament hopefully
they're a playoff team
next season but at the very least it
doesn't feel like they're lost in the
wilderness anymore wow very tempered
expectations hopefully a playoff team
next season i introduce you saying they
got a shot at the chip we're all in on
i'm trying to slow play it here ben um i
was telling everybody
that i that that the bolts were back
last year and it was looking good
up until the all-star break they had
their first all-star
since jimmy butler and paul gasol back
in the day
they made the huge trade for buchovich
and then they had basically their worst
month of the season
and the polls were decidedly not back
after the all-star break so i'm trying
to
trying to temper my expectations here
also on the podcast today though i did
say they're going to sign nicole yokish
in 2023 so
very tempered expectations right there
yeah exactly
no championship this year but an mvp in
a couple of years we'll see
yesterday was one of those life-changing
moments where the world that we live in
was never the same as the one that we
woke up in
where were you when mello signed with
the lakers
[Laughter]
i was so happy to actually see it happen
man it's like
once mello was done with the thunder
once though it was done with the rocket
it just felt like lebron's bringing him
to the lakers at some point i know
lakers fans
have had the mellow photo shops ready
for a decade
at this point so to actually see lebron
and melo
united after a decade and a half in the
nba
it's exciting i mean we're not seeing
lebron and melo from the heat and knicks
days going back and forth with each
other but it's going to be fun to see
them playing on the same team uh it's
just a bummer that they can't get dwyane
wade out of retirement that chris paul
find that gigantic deal with the suns
otherwise we could have the whole banana
boat crew that would have been fun too
but
although never officially photographed
on the banana boat
hey trey you and i had the privilege of
working with the nba working at turner
for a number of years and what's so
special about that place in addition to
the great people who work there
it's the vibe in the studio off camera
because the way it's built down there in
atlanta
you have the different studios and
they're all kind of on top of each other
and there's a green room
a common area where people are passing
through doing their shows or getting
makeup they're having a production
meeting
and you get to rub shoulders with some
of the greatest basketball players of
all
time i remember just walking through the
makeup room one day and there's dwyane
wade
oscar robertson george girvin you're
just a kid in a candy store
you were down there a lot longer than i
was and every day do you have any
moments just from kind of hanging around
behind the scenes with some of the guys
that have stayed with you or stood out i
remember when kevin garnett was
screaming at me about the property taxes
in malibu
uh yeah i got a great kevin garnett
story too um
i'm i grew up just outside of chicago so
i remember seeing
kevin garnett play basketball in high
school i remember that he wasn't even
the best player on his high school team
there was a guy named ronnie field
uh who played farragut back in the day
they said this guy could have been the
next jordan unfortunately
uh he got in a car accident back in
after his high school years so he never
actually made it to the nba but i
brought up something
about seeing kg and ronnie fields play
back in high school you know 25 years
ago or whatever and then he told me
an unbelievable story about ronnie
fields that made it sound like he had a
60 inch vertical
like i don't know about that kg but uh
anytime kevin garnett gets to telling a
story
it's more exciting than any story
anybody else could tell because it's kg
telling it at
full kg intensity the guy doesn't go
halfway
on anything so anytime you anytime it
was like an area 21 day
and there was a kevin garnett was
filming something
it was going to be louder and way more
hype than any other day
in makeup you know i would leave the
locker room after
just talking to kg for like two minutes
i was fired up to do my show i was like
i want to go play defense against
somebody that's up there in the studio
man
i remember the day they had the fondue
machine on set for jason williams and kg
just just discovered white chocolate on
a stick and he was going crazy that was
just a very special day on set
um yeah that's another great moment of
him playing
jenga i think with tony allen and it's
like nobody has been more hyped to play
jenga
ever than kevin garnett was i think you
and i and maybe garnett's family might
have been the only fans of area 21 it's
far too short-lived
like what can't get more kevin garnett
playing jenga that'd be the best
uh trey appreciate you coming on as
you're celebrating the chicago bulls
winning a championship here in august a
big day for you man i'm proud of you i'm
happy for you
i feel like you've won something and
done something but you just haven't but
congratulations yeah i haven't actually
done
anything except for tell people that the
balls are back before they finally came
back but this time
it is for real i mean they signed tony
bradley today
then people are lining up to sign with
the chicago bulls that has never
happened those tony bradley top shots
are going to add nicely to your
collection you're going in on the top
shot i see you talking about it are you
buying more video highlights late at
night i've got every bulls moment that i
can get
so far except for an old jimmy butler
one i gotta pull the trigger on that one
but yeah man for me top shot has been a
nice little hobby it's like uh
i'm watching all of these games anyways
so i might as well continue watching
them in 15 second clips and for me it's
exciting to actually be like oh yeah i
remember when that play had happened i
thought it was going to be a top shot
someday it
actually will be and we'll see what it's
like uh in the future
no dunks is the podcast trey kirby
thanks for showing me around the nba
finals and for
taking some time with us today all right
ben thanks for having me on i'll catch
you when we get a
knicks versus bulls playoff series can
you imagine
like the good old days oh that would be
a lot of fun yeah just hope uh a little
different results this time thanks so
much trey ayo trey kirby joining the
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here